now apple has released software to fix a
security hole that allowed hackers to
infect iphones and other apple devices
without users even doing anything
spyware researchers captured what they
say is a new exploit from nso groups
pegasus spyware tool it was used to hack
the phone of a saudi arabian activist
the tool targets iphones and other apple
devices through imessage
larry majid is ceo of connectsafely.org
and internet safety and privacy
security organization he joins us live
via zoom from san francisco thanks for
being with us uh so just
first of all before we get into the
implications of this talk us through for
the uninitiated among us myself included
how this spyware works
in in hacking into your phone and what
apple has come up with to fix it
well what's particularly concerning
about this spyware is unlike most uh
infections where you have to click on
something or do something it just gets
into your phone
so the user can you know doesn't have to
do anything other than just own a phone
or for that matter a mac or and even an
apple watch and once it infects your
phone then the people behind it have
complete control they can read your
messages turn on your microphone turn on
your camera you have zero privacy so
it's a particularly pernicious type of
uh malware even though it does come from
a company it's not coming from a group
of criminal hackers
it's coming from a company that fails at
the government but that doesn't mean
it's any less dangerous if it gets into
the wrong hands
and
what's to stop a company then like like
pegasus from coming up with its own
updates uh in response to this that will
bypass whatever apple has done i mean is
this always going to be a kind of a a
cat and mouse game here
yeah the the nfl group which is behind
this this product called pegasus is a
legitimate company in a sense and they
say that they only sell to
non-oppressive legitimate governments
but there's nothing to stop a criminal
from getting their hands on it or there
may be things to stop them but it can
still get through to criminals and of
course governments so you know a
government that you might consider to be
benign i might consider to be oppressive
so i you know that's a political issue
but apple is very concerned about it
which is why they uh initiated this
patch i i found out about it today and
immediately updated my iphone i
recommend everyone do that today right
now uh because it's it's very dangerous
and you know apple is trying to prevent
it but hasn't been successful completely
in so doing
uh well that gets to my next question i
mean you mentioned there repeated the
people should update their phones
regularly but what else can we as
ordinary phone users do to
reduce our vulnerability to hackers
well in addition to going through and
updating your phone don't just wait for
it to happen automatically it may happen
but do it now
we can put pressure on companies like
apple and google which makes android to
do a better job at themselves detecting
this kind of malware it was detected by
a third party research group and they
they told apple and apple took action
which is good but i'd like to see apple
be more proactive in detecting it
themselves they say they will have
better security software with their next
version of their operating system that
comes out this fall but you know the
iphone's been on the market for a long
time now and it's not as secure as i
wish it were
good to talk to you uh larry uh maggot
in uh san francisco thank you
thank you